[Music]
there are many devout catholics
in our national political landscape
these days i'm thinking of course of
people like
joe biden nancy pelosi now they might
not
agree with the teachings of holy mother
church
they might not believe the central
tenets of christianity or at least very
important tenets of it they might not
practice their faith but they are devout
nonetheless
because words have no meaning anymore
well fortunately i am i am joined
by a very serious practicing catholic
now one of my favorite people out there
in the catholic media landscape very
sharp fella
by the name of matt fred matt fradd is
the creator and host of pints with
aquinas
he's also the author of how to be happy
saint thomas's secret
to a good life also uh does god exist a
socratic dialogue on the five ways of
thomas aquinas
and he's got lots of other wonderful
commentary out there matt thank you for
joining
me it's great to be on thanks for having
me so
so you on i think some pretty important
issues would probably diverge
from say a joe biden or nancy pelosi
and yet i'm to understand you're both
devout catholics so i
can you can you help me wrap my head
around uh
what these words mean yeah it's
difficult i think
um you know a faithful catholic should
submit to what the church teaches
authoritatively but also not demand
uniformity where the church allows
diversity of opinion or customs so i
think
you can fall off on the left and you can
fall off on the right as far as being a
faithful catholic i try to be a faithful
catholic i try to repent when i'm not
but joe biden promotes and celebrates
the slaughtering of the unborn and i
know that people might be tired of
hearing that
but i imagine if the unborn could be
tired of being slaughtered
you know that that would outrank your
concern so
yeah it's it's disgusting um not to
mention
his promotion of children being able to
say castrate themselves or getting
a double mastectomy he seems ambivalent
on that topic
so yeah he's he's he should repent
before almighty god and look
at i've done some kind of soul searching
on this
and i thought to myself what would i
rather joe biden repent or be
refused holy communion at mass and be
super embarrassed
and to my shame sometimes it's the
latter yeah you know i i
and really as a catholic what i ought to
be doing is praying for him and his
conversion
but of course you know keeping someone
from receiving holy communion refusing
to give them the eucharist
is is an act toward repentance i mean
that is the point it's not just to make
someone feel bad about
himself right it's to stir and promote
repentance because it's not just this
the private sin of his support for
abortion
it's the public sen i mean it's the
scandal as well and it's a real scandal
joe biden is nominally the second
catholic president and yet
he is so so out of step with the
church's teaching here i'm also really
glad that you brought up this issue
of being able to disagree on certain
matters
but not others you know it's not all
just a blanket
five bullet points on a napkin here's
what you've got to believe
for instance on the issue of the death
penalty though especially modern popes
have been
quite opposed to the death penalty pope
benedict put it very well when he said
that catholics may reasonably disagree
on the practice of the death penalty
and it's a complex issue obviously some
popes have carried out the death penalty
i'm thinking of
blessed pope pius ix uh and yet other
popes are vociferously opposed to it
saint paul defends the death penalty
other other writers in the catholic
church have been opposed to it and so
we can have a reasonable disagreement
here even pope francis who's so
so against the death penalty he stopped
short of calling it intrinsically evil
because
he could not do that because it's
defended even in the bible
uh on an issue like abortion that's just
not the case that the church's teaching
on abortion goes back
to the ddake it goes back to the second
century at least
and if not even further back so there
there just seemed to be some lines in
the sand that are getting
much much blurrier at least in the
political sphere
yeah if it's not atrociously wrong for
big strong
people to kill little weak people i'm
not sure what atrocious or wrong would
mean at that point so yeah
and it's important to point out too that
this is not just a matter of us as you
say
making biden feel bad in the code of
canon law
canon 15 it says that those who are
absolutely persevering in in manifest
grave sin should not receive should not
be permitted to receive
uh holy communion and to my fellow
catholics out there who disagree with
that
i would ask them this suppose donald
trump was in office
and donald trump converted to
catholicism i'm pretty sure you
would say that he should not receive
holy communion because you think he's a
sexist or a racist or something
else but of course as as awful
as being a racist or all these sorts of
things
it's actually far worse to slaughter
innocent human beings
of course there's no no real comparison
here and i think very often you know the
the left it is the left that's doing it
i understand there are
extremists on the right too but it's the
left that is really calling for this
inversion
of standards and this bizarre view of
vice and virtue and i'm reminded
i don't want to beat up on the on the
reporter too much but there was a
journalist
who very quickly deleted the tweet so
i've gone light on her
but she tweeted out that we need porn
for children because here's her argument
and i mean it it has a kind of perverse
logic to it she's saying
that kids are accessing porn we know
that they're accessing porn i think the
average age is something like 11 you
know and some kids are accessing it even
at a younger age
and the porn is vile and extraordinarily
perverted and violent very often
and so her argument is since kids are
going to be exposed to porn
we should have a sort of nicer porn you
know where they're not quite so violent
and they're not it's sort of a little
bit uh more gentle
or something like that uh didn't go over
very well and she deleted this but
i suspect a lot of people hold to this
kind of bizarre view
yeah i'm of the opinion that pornography
say consuming pornography the
distribution of it the
the production of it is intrinsically
evil which is just to say
it's not evil because of the intentions
of those viewing it say
nor is it evil merely because of the
consequences of viewing it i think it's
just wrong in and of itself
um so i would say under no circumstances
should people consume pornography
but i think um we could agree that some
things are less bad than others right so
it would be less bad
to view pornography that was not violent
and
terribly degraded than to view
you know rape porn right but just
because something is less bad than
something else
it doesn't make it healthy or good if i
say
i only smoke one carton of cigarettes a
day
not five well that's better but it's not
good not healthy and yeah and over the
last 40 years there's been a lot of
studies that have come out of academia
from
different branches of science like
neurology sociology and psychology and
all of it is saying unambiguously that
porn is detrimental
to the health the emotional health even
the sexual health of the consumer
our relationships and society as a whole
so just just just a couple real quick
there are over 70 studies that show a
correlation between porn use and sexual
dissatisfaction
so there you go according to science if
you'd like to remain sexually frustrated
porn's the ticket there are 56
neuroscience-based studies on porn users
all but one lends strong support for the
addiction model just one more
we have 40 studies that show a
correlation between porn use and
sexual dysfunction like premature
ejaculation erectile dysfunction
12 of those 40 studies show not just
correlation but causation
since in these studies the one factor of
pornography was removed
and the subjects regained their sexual
functioning so we've got really good
reason for thinking that pornography is
bad for us and so introducing it to
children is a
terrifically wicked idea i think also i
i agree with your view on porn and i i
know that some people are trying to make
everything relative they want to deny
that anything is absolutely evil other
than perhaps donald trump he might be
the incarnation of evil everything else
is on a relative scale
but i think what it also gets to is an
error in the way that the human mind
works and the human soul works i think
for a very long time at least since
freud we've been operating under
the steam engine model of the mind and
the soul namely
we've got all this pent up sexual energy
you know and young teenagers are
certainly going to have
lots of pent-up sexual energy and so
they've just got to blow off a little
steam and
you know all of us we all just need to
blow off a little steam whether that
means
you know doing some drug or you know
over indulging in drink or looking at
some porn
you just look if you just blow off a
little steam then it's going to
make you ultimately healthier and
balance you out so you don't explode
but this would seem to contrast with oh
i don't know
old uncle aristotle or saint thomas
aquinas who
recognized that virtue is a habit right
virtue is a practice
and so the and i think we all know this
in our own lives whether it's
going on a diet or whether it's
exercising or abstaining from something
that is harmful to us
the the more that we practice a virtue
the easier it becomes and the more that
we practice a vice whether it's drug
addiction or porn or whatever
the more we practice that the easier
that becomes as well and those
those two views of how the mind works
they're completely at odds with one
another
yeah exactly you know if if if it were
the case that pornography merely
relieved your sexual desires then people
who watch pornography
ought to be sort of sexually carefree in
the sense of satisfied but that isn't
what we see happen what we see is the
more you consume it the more you desire
to consume it
you build up a tolerance what you have
already seen and then feel the need to
view more
deviant forms of pornography interview
uh to view more of it
um so actually i just was struck by an
analogy recently it was by norman
deutsch who wrote the best-selling book
the brain that changes itself
and to your point of habits and vices um
the more we're learning about the brain
and say neural pathways in the brain he
has this great analogy he says suppose
you find yourself in a forest you have
two paths ahead of you
one path represents looking at
pornography the other path represents
abstaining
if you keep going down the path to look
at pornography and have been doing that
since you were eight
that path will be very well worn the
other will be overgrown and more
difficult to walk down but as you say
with time
with habit if you choose to break free
from pornography by getting
you know good books good accountability
good software that this will begin to be
easier to walk down i know that from my
own experience
whereas that the path to look at
pornography you don't just slide into it
as you once did and that's that's really
good news for those struggling well
that's right i mean
mentioning your own experience uh you're
one of the few people who have come out
and said look i dealt with this problem
this is a problem that i've seen as one
study that said it afflicts
91 or 93 of men and the caveat to that
study is that
seven or nine percent of men are liars
you know i really you see it
throughout the culture especially for
young men and you said i've dealt with
this it's an embarrassing problem
but there is a way out of it yeah
yeah i mean i honestly i was maybe it
was a grace from god i was never
terribly embarrassed to share
about it maybe because i encountered so
many other people who said i struggle
but nobody knows
pornography feels good i'm still tempted
to it from time to time if i have a
couple of drinks or if i'm very stressed
out these sorts of things
i think pornography and masturbation
become for many a sort of pacifier to
regulate our emotional turbulence
we turn to it when we're upset or bored
or feel invisible or unsuccessful or
emasculated or something like that
but it doesn't give us her what it
promises
you know we we might go for excitement
we end up bored we might go
for uh you know adult entertainment and
become increasingly juvenile
it just it just it it doesn't just not
give us what it promises
it kind of gives the opposite so it's
entirely unsatisfying
um so that's why i love speaking to men
and women who are hooked on this and say
hey look
you're a lovely person i'm sure or if
you're not you ought to be and you
desire to be
and you don't need to let pawns stand in
your way you know so and compared to
other temptations and vices this is the
one
that is ubiquitous you can do it
entirely almost entirely in the privacy
of your own
uh you know darkest closet though it's
not totally private because big tech
is looking at you and you know there are
records of these things
uh but you know it's not spoken of and
when it is spoken of it's spoken of
positively so much so that people say
that kids should have good porn
and i love the point that you're making
here on satisfaction because
of course yes like all sin and vice
it promises you one thing and it gives
you the opposite and this especially so
but people are historically dissatisfied
you're seeing the average life
expectancy in the united states dropping
not because of the wuhan virus i mean
perhaps then too
but but this was happening for years now
it's dropping because of deaths of
despair
because of drug addiction because of
suicide you've seen
huge spike in suicide actually in some
quarters during the
lockdowns so people are unhappy you look
even you measure the happiness of women
since the women's movement in the middle
of the 20th century
what happened women's happiness if you
can measure it has declined
both in relative terms to men but also
in absolute terms so
everyone's unhappy no one's having kids
you know we've got a very very low birth
rate now
we've got the life expectancy declining
so matt i i need the answer
and you know the five or six minutes we
got what is the secret to a good life
how does how does one have life well
first of all let me say something about
pornography and i'll get into the good
life through it
the problem with pornography it's been
said isn't that it shows too much but
that it shows too little right it
reduces the beauty and mystery of sex
and femininity and masculinity to a sort
of two-dimensional thing for my
consumption so i'm against porn uh
because i'm pro-sex
not not because i'm anti-sex and because
i would like a beautiful fulfilling sex
life in my marriage and i think people
should want that if they're married
and that that porn only gets in the way
of that yeah so i just wrote a book
called
how to be happy saint thomas a secret to
a good life um
thomas aquinas people often think of him
they might think of metaphysics or his
arguments for god's existence or just
war theory or these sorts of things
but he had a lot to say about human
flourishing and he follows aristotle in
that sense where he understands
happiness
to be a sort of an excellence of human
beings and
he distinguishes between two types of
happiness equals one
beatitude one felicitus that's the uh
that's the latin of the greek aristotle
used namely what he's saying is
to be perfectly happy will not happen in
this life
but we can have a high degree of
happiness through virtue
in this life so if you want any chance
of being happy you have to grow in
virtue
flee from vice but since we've been made
ultimately for god thomas aquinas would
say we will not be fully satisfied until
we behold him as it were face to face
in heaven aquinas even goes through a
list of the certain things we turn to to
make us happy like honor and physical
pleasure and
even spiritual pleasure uh money and
these sorts of things and he shows he
he doesn't he doesn't just say can't
make you happy he offers
arguments for why they can't make us
happy um
and i find myself really convicted by it
so yeah it's neat i think for too long
we've thought about morality as thou
shalt not
right don't do what you really want to
do but actually morality is about how to
be happy like how do i live
a life of human flourishing and that's
how thomas understands it how aristotle
understands it and that's what i try to
put in this yeah i just read a book
very old book about 500 years old by dom
lorenzo scoopily called the
the spiritual combat and in it he lays
something out that i know a lot of
people are grappling with
and he just lays it out so simply and so
clearly it's sort of what st paul's
getting at when he says the things i
want to do i don't do and the things
that i don't want to do i do and you
think well how on earth does that make
any sense
and yet we all we all know that that is
true and and what uh scoopily points out
is we have a lower will we you know we
have
we have certain desires but their base
desires their appetites
you know it's the appetite for the
addiction it's the appetite for more
more food more cigarettes more whatever
then we have the higher will that's a
rational will so we we can
be conscious of that we can we recognize
that there's some objective
standard that we're trying to come into
line with and the the rational will
mediates between the appetites which
every animal has
and the divine will which is perfect and
right and just
and so the whole the whole process it's
so funny
how much we forget in our society
because the whole process of a liberal
education
was once understood to be getting that
base will
to come into alignment with the rational
will so that you can actually
be a free person not free in the sense
that you've got an iphone and you can go
look at porn or you've got a syringe and
you can shoot up
but free in the sense that you can
master those appetites and really pursue
what you ultimately desire
yeah in the catechism of the catholic
church under chastity it has this
wonderful line probably my favorite in
the whole catechism it says
the alternative is clear either man
governs his passions and so finds peace
or he lets himself be dominated by them
and becomes
unhappy you you see this in dante one
probably the most famous canto of
dante's
paulo and francesca these adulterous
lovers
and the their punishment is that they
are
whipped around on wins they can't they
can never control they're just going to
be brought along
on the winds and the gusts of lust and
passion that's exactly right
so it is counter-intuitive sometimes we
think or maps we've been told that if
i just engage my passions without
restraint that's the path to happiness
but it seems to me that you only have to
live to the age of 14 to realize that
that doesn't
work and so so what do you yeah maybe
try a different route
what are you seeing happening i actually
have a bit of hope here not only because
it's a
demand and a theological virtue but i
actually think things might be improving
in as much as for a long time at least
in the united states
the conservative movement adopted this
you do you kind of approach to politics
oh yeah we're the cool party we're the
free party yeah look whatever look at
porn or
do drugs or there was a famous essay by
pg o'rourke who's a conservative
humorist
which was called the republican party
reptile had to drive fast on drugs while
getting your wing wang squeezed and not
spill your drink
and it you know it sort of embodied that
1980s 90s vision of what it means to be
a conservative and i'm noticing now the
people who still embrace that thing do
whatever you want just don't make me pay
for it
it's kind of the boomers you know it's
kind of this older gen x it's kind of
this older
crowd on the right and the younger cred
the youths that they think that they're
appealing to that i've spoken to gen z
and even millennials
they don't want that they actually do
want some moral order they do want some
standards and they do want to pursue
virtue are you saying that as well or am
i am i just hallucinating no i'm
yeah no i'm seeing that as well i it
feels like for so long people who have
been more conservative
have tried this sort of incremental
approach and i'm not poo pooing that i
see that there's a there's a reason for
that
but almost like well i don't want to
come off as too radical so yeah maybe
abortion
except for rape and incest and um or
sorry
for no other reason yeah yeah but um it
seems like more and more
it's like no we need to speak the truth
and speak it clearly there is a way to
live there is a way not to live
and if society and culture becomes
poisoned with intrinsically evils
the fruit the children the families out
of that are going to be dysfunctional
and unhappy as well so it seems to me
that we have an
obligation to for the common good and
that we should act in such a way and
even legislate in such a way to bring
that about
of course a republic refers to the
things we hold in common the public
things i mean there's no
we have a constitution to promote the
general welfare
we do live in a society we're not just
atoms floating around in the world born
purely with rights we have obligations
we're in a family in a community
we want to live in a nice place and we
want to have a nice country
and one of the people helping to guide
us back there i think is matt fradd and
i would recommend that everyone go get
the book
how to be happy st thomas's secret to a
good life and really and follow matt's
other stuff too i think you write so
clearly you write so clearly you speak
so clearly you've got a
lot of moral courage uh you know even to
talk about very difficult issues
that a lot of people don't want to talk
about that is just pervading our society
and i think just
that simplicity that clarity is is
really a way to
snap people out of it i i often go back
to ernest hemingway's description of
bankruptcy as a thing that happens
gradually and then suddenly
and you know things can happen suddenly
there can be big shifts
we might be in one of those shifts right
now and i hope we have a good life
and human flourishing for our whole
country matt thanks for being on the
show
thanks michael
you